welcome to Hannity we begin with a Fox
News Alert tonight one person is
emerging as the clear winner from this
week's democratic debates that would be
president from the radical socialists on
stage did not deliver virtually no one
was impressed with any one president
called the debate quote boring Bill
Maher tweeted not a promising start even
congresswoman well the real leader of
the 2020 candidates in the House of
Representatives Alexandria Acacio Cortes
chiming in comparing it to a high school
classroom filled with kids who didn't do
their homework didn't read the book in a
moment will break down all the radical
positions you get to hear it yourself
ill-informed platforms far-left
fantasies that would never happen all
right
also my staff behind my back sent our
own Lawrence Jones to the debate in
Miami yeah to see what Democrats think
about me now I was just told about this
moments ago I can hardly wait take a
look we're gonna play the full package
coming up I'm told that's going to be
quite entertaining but first we turn to
one of the biggest losers from last
night's debate that would be NBC News
they experienced some technical
difficulties at the height of the debate
can happen to anybody take a look I
think we had a little Mike issue in the
back control room we've got we have the
audience are you now right is there a
role for the federal government in order
to play in order to get these guns off
the streets
we are hearing our colleagues audio if
the control room can turn off the
heights of our previous moderators we
will guess what guys we are gonna take a
quick break we're gonna get this
technical situation fixed we will be
right back
well technical glitches they do happen
remember that once we had an anchor was
called going to the bathroom flushing
the toilet that was released on tape
that happens now the real embarrassment
is that NBC allowed the conspiracy
theorists the biggest one in the country
to moderate the debate the so-called
news network they put Roswell Rachel
Maddow right there front and center
again the single biggest conspiracy
theorist in the country we're gonna go
over a lot of these conspiracies he's
just a quick list
she once described herself as left of
Mao and for three years she has been
hysterically breathlessly like the rest
of the media reporting an actual hoax
and she told her viewers President Trump
was a Russian op suggesting Rex
Tillerson a Russian plant saying
Vladimir Putin could turn off the power
in Fargo North Dakota whenever he wanted
comparing Trump's children so nice
liberal kindness judean coos say Hussein
Saddam Hussein's kids
despite her rampant abuse of bias
embarrassing conspiracy theories hatred
all things Donald Trump NBC News a lot
harder to be the moderator camere ushe
Levin how about O'Reilly not all four of
us will do the next debate that's
because NBC News they're not interested
in the truth they're not interested in
integrity or actual journalism instead
NBC News Tom broke are you watching an
even build up this brand TV channel that
works in unison with everything
Democratic Party everything socialist
everything to smear slander besmirched
President Trump every second every
minute every hour of every day and true
to form
Roswell Rachel Maddow or sidekick
Chuckie Todd they didn't ask tough
questions we never expected that instead
they earns their democratic friends on
the stage indulge their far-left
conspiracy theories take a look we're
here in Miami which is already
experiencing serious flooding on sunny
days as a result of sea level rise parts
of Miami Beach and the keys could be
underwater in our lifetimes does your
plan save Miami Nancy Pelosi is saying
that impeachment will not be pursued in
the house it raises the prospect and the
Moller report raises the prospect that
President Trump could be prosecuted for
some of those potential crimes down the
line no US president has ever been
prosecuted for crimes after leaving
office do you believe that President
Trump could or should be the first
anyway one news critic actually called
Roswell Rachel Maddow's performance of
quote lost for journalism we've been
telling you since so 7 & 8 journalism is
dead
buried for many years it's clear NBC
so-called news conspiracy theory TV and
making no attempt to ever revive that
still last night's debate did confirm
what we have also been telling you for
some time
moderates and the Democratic Party well
they're extinct they no longer exist
there are no more Joe Lieberman scoop
Jackson's the radical socialist they
have completely and totally taken over
and last night they were just obsessed
with vilifying private enterprise in
other words that which has created the
greatest standard of living in the
industrialized world that has advanced
the human condition more than any
governmental system capitalism works and
we share it with others take a look who
is this economy really working for it's
doing great for a thinner and thinner
slice at the top we need to make
structural change in our government in
our economy and in our country would you
support a 70% individual marginal tax
rate yes no our path I would support a
tax rate and a tax code that is fair to
everyone tax capital at the same rate
that you you tax ordinary income take
that corporate tax rate up to 28% I
think we have a serious problem in our
country with corporate consolidation and
you see the evidence of that in how
dignity is being stripped from late
we're supposed to be for 70 percent tax
rate on the wealthy we are supposed to
break up big corporations when they're
not serving our democracy there's plenty
of money in this country it's just in
the wrong hands I didn't know who half
these people were but make no mistake
Democrats yeah they want a 70% top
marginal tax rate for individuals and a
90 percent top corporate tax rate and
then a wealth tax and then a death tax
Wow who's gonna want to build business
you wonder why New York New Jersey let's
say Illinois California losing
population yeah because of what they
proposed last night where we gonna go
next but there are not enough by the way
if you look at it billionaires and
millionaires in the world to pay for
this grandiose socialist vision of
theirs let's say free universal basic
income retirement early education child
education Universal childcare paid leave
Family League guaranteed vacation free
housing and of course free universal
health care but you can't pick your
doctor your plan and save money that
didn't work out as a matter of fact
there'll be no choices we all have in
one system the government system who
here would abolish their private health
insurance in favor of a government-run
plan just to show of hands start out
with so yes I'm with Bernie on Medicare
for all
there are a lot of politicians who say
oh it's just not possible we just can't
do it have a lot of political reasons
for this what they're really telling you
is they just won't fight for it would
you replace private insurance no I think
the choice is fundamental to our ability
to get private insurance is not working
for tens of millions of Americans when
you talk about the co-pays that
deductibles the premiums the
out-of-pocket expenses it's not working
not working now below Sabbath Morrigan
selected her first order of business
would be to ban private insurance that's
right if you're watching at home and you
like your insurance you like your doctor
too bad because if elected Elizabeth
Warren will be making and allowing the
government to make all your health care
decisions and you thought Obamacare was
bad how many lost millions lost their
doctors
millions lost their plans everyone paid
a ton more in spite of the promises
given Warren's track record of faking
her ethnicity I don't think that she has
the best judgment but of course the true
litmus test in a democratic party well
that's the issue of abortion and open
borders and everything else some cases
they're outright Fanta side there
endorsing last night the party of
partial some cases yes during an even
post birth abortion yeah they showed
their true colors take a look I don't
believe only in reproductive freedom I
believe in reproductive justice what
that means is that just because a woman
or let's also not forget someone in the
trans community a trans female this poor
doesn't mean they shouldn't have the
right to exercise that right to choose
senator why would you put limits on any
limits on abortion I would make certain
that every woman has access to the full
range of reproductive health care
services we now have an America where
most people support Roe vs. Wade we need
to make that a better law now just to
keep track if you're at home to add it
all up democratic radical socialist
extremists they're promising everything
free taxes through the roof
government-run health care no private
insurance option no limits on abortion
at all regardless of the stage or
pregnancy or survivability of the child
at that point extreme positions not
based in reality and quite frankly in
many cases scary but there's more one
key tenant of the Democratic platform
open borders last night many vilified
the President and Republicans for trying
to deter people from entering this
country legally and of course their
children from making the dangerous trip
through Mexico and it wasn't long ago
that President Obama and his second term
was echoing the concerns of Republicans
sometimes even sound unlike Trump take a
look our message absolutely is don't
send your children
unaccompanied on trains or through
through a bunch of smugglers we don't
even know how many of these kids don't
make it and may have been waylaid into
sex trafficking or killed because they
fell off a train we have no way of
tracking them so that is our direct
message to the families in Central
America do not send your children to the
borders if they do make it they'll get
sent nak more importantly they may not
make it now you might remember the
Democrats expressed no outrage over
those comments in fact there was little
outrage over the mass deportations under
the Obama administration and we had
those pictures that we showed you the
person that fixed it was Donald Trump
remember the conditions under Obama
migrant holding facilities all under
Obama no anger when the Obama
administration put immigrant children
and cages and fake moral outrage is the
Democratic Party's favorite political
weapon
we saw it over Russia and the collusion
hoax they called Trump Russia on Trump a
Russian op but even refused to
acknowledge the role that Hillary
Clinton's dirty bought and paid for
Russian dossier played in the election
played in the whole spying scandal of an
opposition party candidate and then of
course the president-elect and a
president we saw it over the topic of
obstruction of justice they didn't care
about what she did to those 33,000
subpoenaed emails
emma-crats are now obsessed about
phantom obstruction charges against the
president with no underlying crime and
yet when Hillary Clinton bleach pit
acid-wash delete 33,000 emails busting
devices hammers removing SIM cards not a
peep from either the media mob or the
Democratic Party we see it on issues of
racism and sexual assault
don't forget the Democratic lieutenant
governor and governor of Virginia yeah
there's still both in office we see it
on climate change last night four of the
candidates on stage said that climate
change was the biggest threat to our
nation
one said Donald Trump and I assume they
all flew in a plane to last night's
debate I highly doubt that they took a
Prius from the airport either but if the
Democratic Party's moral compass
congresswoman Alec Casio Cortez gets her
way yeah we're gonna ban airplanes and
cows and the combustion engine and gas
and oil the lifeblood of our economy are
absolutely gone you get the picture now
Cassio Cortez weighing in on the
Democratic primary and he's not happy
with the current frontrunner in fact
Acacio Cortez just trashed sleepy creepy
crazy uncle Joe Biden in an interview
with vogue saying that the 76 year old
former VP would depress turnout and is
not a pragmatic choice I actually agree
with her for once anyway if Joe Biden's
small sad kickoff rally is any
indication voters are not excited I
don't see any excitement for any of
these candidates